c'est juste incroyable franchement
c'était même presque devenu un mème
tellement on l'attendait et il est enfin
là le premier trailer de spider man nos
efforts et franchement il y a des
dingueries dedans évidemment je vous
proposais de l'analyser ensemble de le
décrypter de théoriser dessus et vu tout
ce qui lie à dire franchement bas ça va
même sûrement faire l'objet de plusieurs
vidéos donc voilà n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner pour ne rien de bon tout d'abord
il faut ramener le contexte on sort de
spider man far from home à la fin de ce
dernier mystérieux et son équipe ont
partagé une vidéo à la presse le délit
bogle pour révéler que spider man qui
est en fait peter parker aurait tué de
sang-froid mystérieux avec ses drones
lui le grand héros adulé par tous car il
a soit disant sauver le monde des
éléments tôt évidemment nous devons voir
les conséquences de cette fête news et
ce n'est pas anodin dans les comics
spider man qui est très populaire subie
par moments des gros drama médiatique
par exemple il y a le cas avec des
policiers qui en ont ras-le-bol que
spider man fasse le travail à leur place
et du coup il n'est pas aimé par tous
etc les premiers détails à ce sujet il y
avait de grosses rumeurs comme quoi matt
murdock soit daredevil serait présent
dans le film beaucoup pensent qu'il
s'agit de la personne avec la chemise
blanche effectivement si on se réfère
aux rumeurs il pourrait apparaître dans
le film est plus que ça encore il est un
avocat donc ça colle bien à la situation
de peter mais il faut rester quand même
dans le doute bref tout ça pour dire
qu'à la base les dramas médiatique etc
bah ça fait partie de l'histoire
spider man du héros et c'est intéressant
de le voir ici peter est grillé il est
contre tous sa vie va considérablement
changer comme démontré dans le trailer
et du coup cela semblerait servir de
pitch de base de situation initiale en
quelque sorte et cela va amener peter a
rencontré strange ce qui est intéressant
avec ce concept c'est qu'il faut
comprendre que peter est seul
littéralement nick fury était incarnée
par talos il joue la couverture du
véritable nick fury le temps de son
absence mais c'est tout il ne peut pas
servir d'appui pour la jeune araignée
tony est mort et il n'avait pas de lien
particulier avec les autres avengers à
l'exception de strange avec qui il a
partagé un bout d'histoire dans infinity
ward d'ailleurs petit mot concernant le
costume noir que l'on voit très
rapidement dans le trailer mais pour moi
il s'agit bien évidemment d'une sorte de
costume de camouflage qui sert en même
temps de référence à la tenue de venom
évidemment en gros cette nuit là pour ne
pas qu'il se fasse reconnaître puisque
spider man est traqué recherché par tous
étant l'ennemi public numéro un mais
nous aurons l'occasion de revenir sur le
costume plus en détail à l'avenir donc
c'est une pierre deux coups strange est
le seul héros qui peut comprendre la
situation de peter et qu'il connaît un
petit peu puis il semble être capable de
pouvoir l'aider et c'est là que c'est
marrant car l'élément de résolution qui
est censé apporter strange avec son
sortilèges se transformerait plutôt en
une sorte d'élément perturbateur pour
l'intriguent en fait il ya quelque chose
qu'on a tendance à très souvent faire
c'est sûr côté docteur strange
effectivement strange est censé être le
meilleur des sorciers suprême il est
l'un des avengers les plus puissants
néanmoins il est encore au stade de
découverte par moments est pire que ça
ils font souvent tête baissée et il est
très arrogant ce n'est pas le genre à
faire de la théorie mais plutôt à
bidouiller et faire de la pratique
rappelez-vous de son premier film où il
s'est fait engueuler par wang est mort
d'eau à cause de son essai de manipuler
la pierre du temps et l'oeil d'agde à
moto bref et c'est quelque chose que je
théorisé déjà dans de précédentes vidéos
mais strange en gros ne connaît rien aux
multivers enfin plutôt dans le sens où
il ne l'a jamais pratiqué il n'a jamais
voyagé encore dedans et c'est donc
l'idée que strange fasse une bêtise en
quelque sorte beh je ne trouve pas ça
incohérent et comme on le pensait
beaucoup et notamment via la bêtise de
strange du coup et bien les portes du
multivers s'ouvrirait en quelque sorte
première petite idée ce que demande
peter a strange c'est que le monde
entier oublie l'identité de spider man
chose qu'il va tenter de faire sauf que
ça semble foiré et comme le dit strange
nous avons altérer la stabilité de
l'espace temps le multivers est un
concept dont nous savons trop peu de
choses alors est-ce que ce sortilège
aurait split la réalité en deux du genre
celle de base et une autre où le sort
aurait marché où tout le monde aurait
oublié l'identité de spider man ou bien
ce sortilège aurait-il fait fusionner
plusieurs réalités en une d'où la
présence des sinistres 6 en fait le
problème et l'ambiguïté du sortilège car
le but est de faire oublier l'identité
de spider man mais je vois mal un sort
qui fasse perdre simplement se souvenir
précis à tout le monde à la harry potter
cela semblerait plutôt correspondre à
une sorte de remodelage de la réalité ce
que je veux dire c'est que normalement
rien ne peut être véritablement corrigé
dans le mc eu comme l'utilisation du
voyage dans le temps d'un game par
exemple le passé n'a pas été modifié ou
bien même la manipulation de réalité de
nexus comme dans owen la vision je ne
sais pas si j'arrive à être assez clair
cependant de ce que nous voyons dans le
trailer et par rapport à ce que dit
strange à peter comme quoi c'est lui le
problème essayant de vivre de vie à la
fois tout se beau bazar de réalité et
réunissant les six mr 6 résultait de
l'état mental de peter qui est lui même
divisé entre deux identités concernant
aux longues du coup nous savons déjà que
ce dernier ne reste plus cloîtrée dans
le sanctuaire à servir strange il
apparaît d'ailleurs dans ce chan chee où
il semble affronter l'abomination est
justement ce qui est intéressant est que
wang mais très souvent en garde strange
dans les comics jusqu'au jour où il va
aller trop loin wang qui définitivement
strange à un moment donné dans les
comics pour des raisons qui ressemble un
petit peu au cas du film spider man from
du style strange a trop bravé l'interdît
quoi je ne m'avance pas trop pour le
moment mais je suis quand même curieux
de la réaction de wang quand il va
apprendre tout ça mais peut-être qu'ils
feront un effet comique en mode et il ne
s'est rendu compte de rien où il ne
s'est rien passé du coup voilà quoi mais
le problème étant que spider man 3d
coule sur doctor strange de multivers of
madness ce qui signifie forcément que
tout ce beau bazar de réalité cela ne va
pas être véritablement conclu avec ce
film bon maintenant il va bien falloir
commencer à traiter des sinistres 6 je
vais d'ailleurs en profiter pour caser
quelques petits morceaux d'une vidéo que
j'étais censé vous sortir sur spider man
nous sommes évidemment à la grande
surprise je ne m'attendais pas à ce que
le trailer fuite et qu'il sorte
officiellement le lendemain donc voilà
je me servir un peu de cette vidéo en
même temps alors on attendait tous ce
moment beaucoup d'informations avaient
fuité comme le retour de william dafoe
et d'autres avaient été confirmés comme
molina en doc ou bien jamie foxx en
électro et bien cela semble aller encore
plus loin c'est désormais oubliée nous
aurons les sinistres 6 en entier puisque
effectivement d'après les images du
trailer nous avons la présence d'
éclairs symbole d'électro un des membres
des sinistres 6 nous avons la présence
des bombes du bouffon vert et de son
célèbre rire ou encore octopus lui même
mais cela ne semble pas s'arrêter là
certains y voient également par exemple
l'homme sable beaucoup de rumeurs ont
également circulé sur le retour de
williams bakker le souci est que la
séquence avec le sable semble être
simplement l'impact des éclairs
d'électro sur le sol mais tout reste
possible beaucoup pensent aussi à la
présence du lézard notamment le moment
où peter est dans le noir et quelque
chose me surprend quelqu'un a d'ailleurs
réussi à bien gérer la luminosité et la
netteté du trailer donc c'est sûr que
c'est en fait j'ai presque envie de dire
que ça coulerait de source que ces deux
personnages ferait partie des sinistres
6 car ce sont les deux méchants restants
qui font partie des films de spider man
de l'époque par exemple il ne manque
plus que l'homme sable entre guillemets
sur la trilogie de sam raimi et du coup
bas le lézard puisqu'il ya électro par
rapport à the amazing spider man en gros
cinq films et 5 méchant mais qui serait
le dernier du coup et bien
personnellement je m'attendrais presque
à un mystérieux déjà il ya toujours eu
une ambiguïté sur la mort de mystérieux
quand un mec est un maître de la
tromperie avec ses effets spéciaux on ne
sait pas comment il a réussi à produire
une vidéo sur sa mort pour plomber peter
et ses associés sont toujours en service
néanmoins effectivement il n'a plus les
drones etc cependant si la situation de
base et le drama médiatique lancée par
mystérieux dans la cohérence du film ce
sera un élément qui sera réglé à la fin
admettons dépassant film le véritable
mystérieux qui est toujours en vie
toujours en train de semer la terreur
avec les autres sinistres 6 et du coup
prouvant qu'il est l'antagoniste et
en peter parker d'ailleurs concernant
les sinistres 6 comme je vous en avais
déjà parlé dans de précédentes vidéos
sony possède dans ses cartons un film
dédié aux sinistres 6 depuis des années
mais ils ne l'ont jamais sortie encore
un film comme spider man noir comme
n'aurait pas vraiment le temps de
développer proprement les sinistres 6 on
parle quand même de six personnages
alors que c'est un film dédié à peter
parker tome hollande accompagné de
doctor strange donc il se pourrait que
le film soit prévu un jour ou l'autre
pour justifier tout ça est justifié du
coup nos héros et par rapport à tobey
maguire et andrew garfield déjà
évidemment sony n'aurait jamais partagé
leur présence dès le premier trailer ce
sont les guest stars attendues donc ils
vont encore attendre pour faire monter
la sauce si ils sont dans le film bien
évidemment sauf que pour moi c'est
quelque chose dont je voulais vous
parler mais c'est une obligation qu'il y
ait toby maguire et andrew garfield dans
spider man noël tout d'abord en terme d'
équilibre aussi bon soit strange et
pieters ils doivent faire face à 6
ennemis réunis et bien c'est un énorme
challenge un petit coup de main ne
serait pas de refus par rapport aux
conflits internes qui ronge peter sur la
révélation de son identité et les
risques et les conséquences que cela en
cours les deux autres spiderman vétéran
pourrait l'aider concernant cette
thématique peter qui est toujours seul
avec ses problèmes de super héros aurait
deux mentors qui ont connu exactement
les mêmes problèmes que lui puisque ils
sont aussi des spider man et sans
oublier ce que j'appelle le syndrome de
cahier des charges pour ceux qui ne sont
pas familiers avec le terme cahier des
charges en gros dites vous que chaque
super héros à une personnalité des
traits de caractère propre des pouvoirs
des faits marquants le concernant dans
les comics etc etc bref toute une liste
définie qu'il faut respecter et
retrouver dans les films par exemple
dans le mc hugh tom holland a déjà pu
nous montrer plein de choses concernant
spider man comme ça attentes mais par
exemple mj les toiles d'araignées le
spyder sense des gros vilain comme
mystérieux propre à spider man etc sauf
que il faut avancer et faire évoluer le
super héros toujours vers une version
encore plus puissante est encore
meilleur qu'avant et pour moi avec le mc
il reste au moins un fait marquant qu'on
n'a pas encore vu à l'écran concernant
spider man et qui est vraiment hyper
important et d'ailleurs cela colle
parfaitement avec la phase 4 c'est le
spyder verse déjà le spyder verts c'est
un élément central de la vision et la
stratégie marketing de sony pictures
nous avons eu un film d'animation dédié
au spyder verse sony aimerait relier le
spider man de tom holland avec leurs
films comme venom ou bien un mort bus
par exemple ils développent leur spyder
verse depuis des années et maintenant
qu'ils ont réussi à s'entremêler avec
les projets de disney ils ont les moyens
de le faire proprement en live action le
spyder verse est une thématique qui va
permettre à peter de relativiser
concernant son identité comprendre qu'il
n'est pas le seul spider man que
beaucoup sont déjà passés par là voir
qu'ils n'ont jamais connu le stade de
super héros c'est vraiment un événement
fondamental du personnage de spider man
dans les comics donc personnellement par
rapport à ça tout ce que je viens de
vous dire autour du spyder verse par
rapport aux sinistres 6 lié à leurs
films précédents et bien pour moi il y
aura bel et bien andrew garfield et
tobey maguire dans le film d'ailleurs je
vous avoue avoir un questionnement par
rapport à la présence de ces sinistres 6
dans nos héros car on nous bassine
depuis le début qu'ils sont les
véritables méchant de leurs films
respectifs du style doc hoc revient
depuis spider man 2 pour nos héros mme
le souci étant que par exemple toc toc
n'est pas quelqu'un de mauvais dans son
film il se fait simplement contrôlés par
l'ia de ses bras et réussit même à
reprendre le contrôle à la fin pour se
sacrifier et sauver le monde il n'a rien
contre peter à la base il l'apprécierait
même plutôt bien et c'est un peu le même
souci pour des méchants comme l'homme
sable par exemple qui est juste un mec
en cavale avec des remords c'est ça le
truc c'est que si ils sont bel et bien
les méchants d'origine de l'époque et
bien cela va un petit peu contredire
voir casser ce café par exemple sam
raimi à l'époque cela ne va pas
respecter ce qu'il a établies dans les
films donc voila nous aurons l'occasion
d'en reparler mais n'oubliez pas que le
multiverse peut proposer une infinité de
versions des sinistres 6 il se pourrait
que les acteurs étaient été repris pour
le symbole pour rejouer ces méchants qui
leur colle à la peau où ils ont marqué
le public avec mais ce ne serait pas
foncièrement les mêmes que dans leurs
films il faut rester un minimum dans le
doute je conclue rapidement sur un petit
ligue de l'époque jamie foxx avait
partagé une image montrant les trois
spider man réunis face à un ciel rempli
des clercs histoire d'annoncer son
retour en tant qu électro il disait
d'ailleurs dans le poste qu'il était
heureux de rejouer ce méchant qui cette
fois n'était plus bleue le trailer nous
a montré des éclairs jaune et jamie foxx
qui avait dû supprimer son poste nous
montrer la réunification des trois
spider man encore une possible preuve de
la réunification des trois speedy et ah
oui j'oubliais presque il y à un moment
où peter tient une sorte de cube entre
les mains c'est forcément un des
artefacts de strange mais lequel je vous
avoue ne pas avoir trouvé j'ai bien une
petite idée mais cela paraît trop gros
pour ce soit ça le cube de pandémonium
un artefact lié à méphisto et dont nous
avons déjà vu un artefact dans le film
the doctor strange liés à ce personnage
en gros ce cube permet justement de
déformer la réalité
donc voilà mais bon ça me paraît quand
même gros si vous avez des idées
n'hésitez pas bon je pense qu'on va
s'arrêter là comme je vous disais c'est
une première vidéo je pense que nous
allons en faire plusieurs parce qu'il ya
vraiment beaucoup de choses à dire je ne
vais pas vous le cacher je suis vraiment
très content et à la fois très
chamboulée car nous y sommes enfin le
trailer est enfin là comme je vous
disais c'était presque devenu un mème
tellement l'attenté était longue mais
bon voilà j'espère en tout cas que ma
vidéo vous aura plu c'est le moment de
débattre sur le film sur ce trailer
faites moi part de vos ressentis en
commentaire de vous idc c'est toujours
un plaisir de vous lire évidemment je
vous ai proposé comme d'habitude une
version personnelle de la chose hein il
est possible que je me goure
complètement ou que l'on interprète pas
tout simplement les éléments de la même
manière donc à vous de me dire en tout
cas n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit
pouce bleus à vous abonner à la chaîne
c'est très important surtout qu'il va y
avoir d'autres vidéos sur le sujet et
puis voilà quoi n'hésitez pas à monsieur
non plus sur instagram et twitter que le
lay en hard soit avec vous c'était targo
rock allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]